pour l'exemple d'ovicenco sur cette
route au nord de Kiev le souvenir du
mois qu'il a passé à défendre la
capitale est encore frais à l'époque pas
une voiture à l'horizon sur la route des
checkpoint partout mais aujourd'hui la
vie est revenue le président américain
nous a même rendu visite
[Musique]
mais un peuple est loin la destruction
est totale
à hostomètre les forces russes ont
échouées à traverser la rivière pin ils
ont donc installé des ponts flottants
plus au nord et tenter de rejoindre Kiev
par le village de moschoun
à l'extrémité ouest de moschool
de là ils ont tiré sur nos unités dans
le centre du village
vous voyez tout est détruit ici mais
l'ennemi n'est pas allé plus loin
ils sont venus de la bave vous voyez ils
n'ont pas pu amener de soutien
logistique ni de renfort ni de munitions
assez vite
et ici ils ont vu notre résistance
renforcée par quelques armes occidental
arriver juste à temps
on venait juste de recevoir déjà l'un
des Stingers et des
nlawn
mais comme on dit on n'a jamais assez de
bonnes choses
et ils ont joué un rôle important dans
notre victoire
dans les tous premiers temps de la
guerre le succès de moschoon a ancré en
Ukraine une conviction la Russie n'est
pas invincible mais cette victoire n'est
pas sans prix
quand je viens ici
je vois défiler devant mes yeux toutes
les personnes qui ont perdu leur vie ici
même
c'est dur
voilà donc